North Korea says its latest missile
launches were to test its tactical
nuclear weapons which it said were to
wipe out U.S and South Korean targets
Kim Jong-un also acknowledged plans to
conduct more of the tests Kim said the
launchers were in response to Joint
Naval drills between the U.S and South
Korea Rob McBride has more details from
song
the North Koreans have said very little
about this flurry of Miss ballistic
missile activity that's gone on pretty
uh much on unchecked for two weeks
continual launching of these missiles
the last week of September the first
week of October and then today Monday
the official North Korean news agency
comes out with almost a pronouncement a
long Declaration of exactly what it's
been doing the dates of the tests the
types of missiles being launched and
tested with photographs showing Kim
Jong-un the North Korean leader
overseeing all of these tests and
basically the headline to come away from
this is that the North Koreans say that
all that they have been doing is uh
carrying out what they call tactical
Nuclear drills this is the supposed
development of a smaller tactical
Nuclear devices now these are the the
kind of miniaturized nuclear warheads
that you would put onto a rocket or a
short-range ballistic missile it it does
require an awful lot of a technical
advancement of technology and
technological know-how in order to do
this and it's unclear just how advanced
the North Koreans are in developing
tactical nuclear warheads but certainly
they are working on the delivery systems
for these types of of warheads they've
also as well as carrying out a shorter
range ballistic missiles probably the
most serious development over the past
couple of weeks was last last week on
October the 4th they launched an
intermediate range ballistic missile
right over the top of Japan that landed
in the Pacific Ocean that caused obvious
alarm from all of North Korea's
neighbors it's the first time they've
carried out such a launch like that in
five years and the North Koreans say
that that is a new type of missile they
also say that they have been practicing
and developing the technology to have um
to have explosions in the air above the
ground now that's the kind of delivery
that you would use if you were launching
a nuclear device